tell us about the dock my way and why
you had to make it what sparked the idea
certainly so the dock my way came about
as a byproduct of our band's fervent
need to make our first music video so we
were in a very small town in western
Pennsylvania very far from Hollywood and
something like making a music video
would be like just outside of the realm
of what people can imagine doing but I
was fortunate enough to have maintained
a pretty good friendship with my
bandmates Holly who's also in the film
and her husband's a director and they
had had relocated to Los Angeles and he
was doing the movie thing so his best
friend was willing to make a music video
for us so our band decided well we need
to go we need to take advantage of this
opportunity and when we thought about it
if we really wanted to do it on a budget
we were really gonna have to come all
the way out to LA to do it we needed to
be here for any kind of planning we
needed to do and to just take on as much
of the burden of the expenses in the
work of making a music video and making
sure it was awesome off of the director
Marcus who's also in the film because he
was doing it for free so the movie
itself came about as a byproduct of okay
how are we gonna get there to make this
video okay what else can we do that
would be related to the band as a part
of this adventure and we came up with
the idea of promoting because we had
been promoting around western
Pennsylvania you know we're in a pretty
rural part of the country and close to
the biggest city of Pittsburgh Binger
our largest city that was close by and
it's not even you know one of the hugest
cities in the country so um
you know we had played
local bars and we played that Hard Rock
Cafe there and that was the most epic
venue in Pittsburgh and done everything
we could there but we knew we were
effective so we thought why not just
take this town the town and then why not
film it and we can make that all part of
the same time investment of getting to
do this video and just go to Los Angeles
so that's how the movie came about
you